[Music]
so welcome to another stories from the
stores I'm here with Ben Russell curator
of mechanical engineering and we've got
the credo of Joseph Clement so Ben
what's the credo what's a credo good
question yeah well it's a statement of
intended what this thing does is little
tiny notebook yeah it establishes a sort
of moral compass as a young man starting
out in the world okay so question number
two who was Joseph Clement he's a young
guy so when he writes this was about
seventeen not it's dated Lewis's 1793 so
he's about 14 and he eventually becomes
one of the most incredible engineers in
London during the 19th century okay but
the big thing he made was the analytical
engine yes so what what Clement does he
builds with averagely of the different
engine and the analytical engine which
is still in the museum's collections the
most and they are the most astonishing
precision machines no one else could
have done it probably except Clement and
those people who work with so this is
like near the Industrial Revolution yeah
so he's up in Cumbria and it's a very
isolated place and he said I'm going to
go to London because that's where it's
all happening at this time there's a
chance he actually might have taken the
book with him so he's up there and he
sort of starting to write this sort of
practising his signature practicing
handwriting doing the old sketches and
missing go he'll you know what does he
want to do with his life and there's a
wonderful little quote which I marked in
here the acquisition of knowledge is one
of the most vulnerable occupations of
youth what are you saying you know go
out there and Hoover up information and
it you know it's gonna you gonna take it
in and someone else ought to come out in
other ways and he goes out there and he
trains himself up self-taught and he
ends up there's one of the most
significant machine builders in London
is it worth someone today writing a
credo
I think it probably is yeah because it
was very clearly what he's doing he was
sitting at the foundations from what he
wants to do next
are there any quotes in there that like
sum up Joseph Clement this man we are
dazzled with the ostentation the
pleasure of learning and the noise of
victories and actually all his modesty
actually was a very victorious man in
terms of his career he did some
wonderful wonderful things that sort of
subdued sort of Lee
[Music]
you